♪
>> Brian: HERE WE GO BOOSTER
SHOTS AND DELTA VARIANT WERE THE
MAIN TOPICS ON DISCUSSION ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY WHERE
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI AND THE CDC
DIRECTOR ROCHELLE WOLENSKI
TESTIFIED ON THE STATE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE ARE LIVING THROUGH.
ALSO ON THE DOCKET NORTHERN
VERBAL BRAWL BETWEEN FAUCI AND
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
OBVIOUSLY THESE TWO HAVE A LOT
TO TALK ABOUT.
>> DR. FAUCI, KNOWING THAT IT IS
A CRIME TO LIE TO CONGRESS, DO
YOU WISH TO RETRACT YOUR
STATEMENT OF MAY 11TH WHERE YOU
CLAIMED THAT THE NIH NEVER
FUNDED GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
IN WUHAN?
>> SENATOR PAUL, I HAVE NEVER
LIED BEFORE THE CONGRESS.
AND I DO NOT RETRACT THAT
STATEMENT.
SENATOR PAUL, DAY NOT KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT, QUITE
FRANKLY.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
OFFICIALLY.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> THE GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
WAS GOING ON IN THAT LAB AND NIH
FUNDED THAT.
YOU CAN'T GET AWAY FROM IT.
IT MEET YOUR DEFINITION AND YOU
ARE OBFUSCATING THE TRUTH.
>> I'M NOT OBFUSCATING.
YOU ARE IMPLYING THAT WHAT WE
DID WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATHS OF INDIVIDUALS.
I TOTALLY RESENT THAT.
>> AND IT COULD HAVE BEEN.
>> IF ANYBODY IS LYING HERE,
SENATOR, IT IS YOU.
>> Brian: UNFORTUNATELY TIME WAS
UP.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME FOR US TO GET
SENATOR RAND PAUL'S TAKE ON
THIS.
SENATOR FROM, MY HUMBLE POINT OF
VIEW, WATCHING THIS A FEW TIMES,
YOU TRIED TO SAY WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN THAT LAB FROM A PAPER YOU
WERE READING AND IT'S DEFINED AS
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
HE WANTED TO FOCUS ON IN
PARTICULAR A CERTAIN EXPERIMENT.
YOU ARE TRYING TO SAY THAT HE
WAS NOT ACCURATE MAY 11TH WHEN
HE SAID THERE WAS NONE OF THAT
FINANCED BY THE NIH.
CORRECT?
>> WELL, GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH IS DEFINED BY THE NIH.
WE READ THE DEFINITION TO HIM.
IT'S WHEN YOU TAKE AN ANIMAL
VIRUS AND YOU MAKE IT MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE OR MORE DANGEROUS
OR MORE LIKELY TO CAUSE A
DISEASE IN HUMANS.
SO WE PRESENTED A PAPER FROM THE
WUHAN INSTITUTE BY A DOCTOR SHI
WHERE SHE TOOK VIRUSES, COMBINED
TWO VIRUSES THAT WERE NOT
INFECTIOUS IN HUMANS AND MADE
THEM INFECTIOUS IN HUMANS.
WE QUOTED A SCIENTIST FROM
RUTGERS UNIVERSITY WITH 30-YEAR
HISTORY IN CELLULAR BIOLOGY WHO
SAID IT WAS THE EPITOME OF GAIN
OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
ALL DR. FAUCI COULD DO WAS
SPUTTER, AND CALL ME LIAR BUT HE
NEVER AT ANY POINT IN TIME
ADDRESS ANY OF THE FACTS THAT WE
LAID OUT THAT THE MONEY HE WAS
GIVING TO WUHAN WAS INDEED FOR
GAIN OF FUNCTION.
>> Brian: THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS IS AMERICAN MONEY USED TO
FINANCE EXPERIMENTS THAT WE
DIDN'T WANT DONE IN THE WUHAN
LAB WHERE TO SEEMED MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE ARE AGREEING WITH
THE ORIGINAL ASSESSMENT AND TOM
COTTON'S ORIGINAL ASSESSMENT
THAT THAT'S WHERE THIS WHOLE
PANDEMIC STARTED FROM.
THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IF
IT'S AMERICAN DOLLARS BEING USED
AND DR. FAUCI KNEW ABOUT IT AND
IS TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM
RESPONSIBILITY FROM IT.
>> YEAH.
HE HAS A SIGNIFICANT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST SINCE HE WAS, INDEED,
AT THE TOP OF THE FOOD CHAIN AND
THAT HE DID APPROVE FUNDING TO
THE NIH TO THE WUHAN LAB.
THAT'S NOT EVEN CONTESTED.
HE KNOWS THAT HE APPROVED THE
FUNDING, ALL HE IS SAYING IS OH,
WELL, THE RESEARCH NOW DOESN'T
MEET OUR DEFINITION.
BUT WHEN YOU READ THE NIH
DEFINITION OF GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH AND YOU TALK TO OTHER
SCIENTISTS THEY ARE SAYING IT'S
THE EPITOME OF GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
SO, YES, HE IS DANCING AROUND
THE TRUTH.
WHY?
BECAUSE IF THIS DISEASE CAME
FROM THE LAB AND THEY WERE
FUNDING GAIN OF FUNCTION, GUESS
WHAT?
THERE IS AT THE VERY LEAST MORAL
CULPABILITY HE HAS FOR THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
BUT IF YOU GO BACK TO FAUCI'S
STATEMENTS IN 2012 HE SAID THAT
THE RESEARCH WAS WORTH IT EVEN
IF A PANDEMIC SHOULD OCCUR.
EVEN IF A LEAK FROM A LAB SHOULD
OCCUR THE RESEARCH WAS WORTH IT.
HE SHOWS INCREDIBLY BAD
JUDGMENT.
>> Brian: SENATOR RAND PAUL, HOW
WAS YOUR EXCHANGE COVERED TODAY?
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE SO-CALLED OBJECTIVE SOURCES
OF NEWS, THEY PLAYED ONLY ONE
SIDE.
THEY DIDN'T LOOK AT ALL.
BUT THIS IS SORT OF THE PROBLEM
WE.
FAUCI CONTROLS ALL THE FUNDING
AND THE MEDIA IS ALL ON HIS
SIDE.
SO YOU REALLY -- NOBODY
QUESTIONED WHAT I HAD SAID.
THEY JUST BROADCAST THAT FAUCI
CALLED ME A LIAR.
SO NAME-CALLING BECAME THE ISSUE
OF THE DAY FOR THE LEFT WING
MEDIA.
>> Brian: A LOT OF DOCTORS ARE
FRUSTRATED THAT DR. FAUCI IS THE
FACE OF THIS, NEVER TURNED DOWN
AN INTERVIEW FROM SELF-CURRY'S
PODCAST TO MSNBC 3:00 A.M. SHOW.
MARTY MAKARY HAS BEEN FRUSTRATED
THE WAY IT'S CHARACTERIZED AND
DOING A STUDY JOHN HOPKINS HOW
THE MONEY IS BEING USED NIH
08000000000 PLUS.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE TOLD ME ON THE
RADIO TODAY.
>> THE REALITY IS I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THE DATE THAT.
HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF HIMSELF
BY THE WAY.
THE NIH LAST YEAR SPENT
$41 BILLION ON RESEARCH GRANTS,
0.4% OF THAT WENT TO COVID.
IF IS HE SO CONVINCED THAT MASKS
ARE NEEDED IN KIDS TWO AND A
HALF YEARS OLD, WHY DIDN'T HE
FUND THE STUDY?
>> Brian: HE HAS 80 BILLION.
HE GIVES OUT 40.
HE CIPS 41 AND PUTS 0.4% INTO
COVID-19 RESULTS AND STUDIES.
HOW DO YOU GET AWAY WITH THAT?
>> WELL, HAS BEEN THERE FOR 40
YEARS, PROBABLY 39 YEARS TOO
LONG.
EVIDENCE CONTROLS ALL THE
FUNDING.
SO PEOPLE ARE DEATHLY AFRAID OF
HIM.
RESEARCHER ALSO NOT SPEAK OUT.
WHY HAVE THERE NOT BEEN OTHER
SCIENTISTS?
I GET FOX NEWS ALERTS SCIENTISTS
ALL THE TIME.
CAN YOU FIND THEM.
THEY ARE VERY DISTRUSTFUL OF
WHAT HE IS SAYING.
THEY DON'T THINK HE IS MAKING
SENSE AND READING THE SCIENCE
ACCURATELY.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM ARE
UNIVERSITY SCIENCE AND THEY
DEPEND O